so uh so james he just dropped a big a
big story yes sir not as big as a
jeffrey toobin thing but you know
correct yes depends upon how big that is
before we go in
oh my gosh for anyone that doesn't know
you run project veritas i run project
veritas where the nation's
premier under perhaps the nation's only
undercover or even investigative
reporting organization we use video
in controversial video evidence and we
just launched a story uh
an hour ago on google a google engineer
discussing how the algorithms are skewed
to favor joe biden in the presidential
election cool time so we
we will definitely lead with this and
i've got uh your website pulled up we'll
look at it
but i'll just add you you may be the
only undercover news outlet in the
country and
man do they hate you but we'll we'll
we'll get into all the so much to say
about that yeah so
we'll leave with this big story so we
can pull this up real quick just to give
people a quick glimpse but instead of
reading through what your website says
you're here you can tell us but i'll
read the headline
senior google manager on search engines
power you are just plain and simple
trying to play god
the powers in the search trump says
something misinformation you're going to
delete
if a democratic leader says that then
you're going to leave it
so how about you just tell us what's
going on what's this breaking story well
this is a this is a guy ritesh lakhar
technical program manager at google and
he works for the cloud and he's talking
about
he's he's kind of an unwitting
whistleblower he talks about how the
corporation plays god and i'm reading
here
uh like if it was fraud it doesn't
matter but for trump or melania it
matters
on the other side trump says something
misinformation you're going to delete
that because it's illegal or whatever
pretext
he talks about the double standard it's
something we all suspect to be true but
he says if a democratic leader says that
then you're just going to leave it
and he talks about how how the corporate
google is outsourcing jobs
to in order to spy on americans and he
feels guilty about this and he describes
the algorithm
how people cry in the corridors of
google uh
when trump won so a lot of what veritas
does is confirm
suspicions right none of this is
surprising to you but it may be one of
the first times you ever heard
them say it as a current employee that's
why we use hidden cameras
people are more honest sometimes uh the
newsworthiness is such that
people talk about the ethics of
recording maybe a good man saying this
but
the public's right to know is paramount
it's important that we we we show this
information to the businesses
this guy says something about training
chinese people
to spy on america and something like
that what yeah he says in this tape
that he feels guilty he feels quote
suffocated at google
and particularly guilty for outsourcing
jobs overseas in order to
spy on the american people one point in
the conversation we ask
why is it that google prefers democrats
and his answer
well this is america very very
enlightening video and this is part one
of a series of videos we'll release a
video every day this week
on google a different different employee
i tweeted out
your video and the first responses from
people was
can't see it it's i can't see it's
unavailable so so there's a there's a
tweet
that i've been getting the same thing
sitting here right now and it says quote
this tweet might include sensitive
content to view it you need to change
your privacy settings
you know what i love i love the irony of
you literally exposing manipulation
interference and censorship and then
they censor you it's it's the perfect
you know i always say this the the best
way to describe irony to to
define irony is a fire truck on fire
like the
that's irony like the fire truck is
supposed to put the fire out not in
flames
you're exposing these big tech companies
and they're actively shutting you down
in real time they're actively doing it
they've always done it but you know
we have a saying at project veritas
content is king right so
you know you just got to do the good
work you got to expose it you got to put
it out there
get proxies to put it out there we
embargo we embargo clips with people
ahead of time
you know sometimes i do that with you
tim i'll share a little link that's true
and um and that's why the new york times
called it a misinformation campaign
because we were embargoing clips with
people ahead of time which is what
reporters always do
but that's why i brought this book with
me 1984. if you haven't read
it since you were 15 reread the book
listen to it on an audible whatever you
do
that looks like it's a 1984 printing it
looks like yeah i think this is my high
school book that i i
i took so yeah the embargo thing is
important too
because that it is extremely common
people don't realize it and the new york
times tried smearing you
simply because you did it simply because
we did it they this is this is something
we should talk about at some point i can
mention it now the
new york times talked to researchers at
stanford university
interviewed them and they said well it's
probably part of a disinformation
campaign because james o'keefe shared it
with my pillow guy
two days before he met with mike lindell
because he's a big-time deal in
minnesota he's a minnesota guy and we're
doing a minnesota story he's got a big
following hey mike
here's a tease of what we're doing and
stanford university told the new york
times well that's the reason it's
probably disinformation usa today quotes
the disinformation part and suddenly
facebook is censoring the video because
usa today says it's disinformation
straight out of orwell so i don't know
what else there is to say about uh you
know
you've got another guy it's not the
first time you've caught somebody we've
all but here's what's crazy to me
we've seen other videos like this the
verge actually i think it was the verge
who published this video
yes where you see them giving a meeting
about donald trump one and we're all
scared and sad
and people are crying that was a
left-wing publication you also had
gizmodo this was back in i think
2018 yeah where they wrote one of the
first stories saying facebook actively
censored conservative news websites
yes you you confirm all this and it's
misinformation
they publish it no it's fine well i
think it's the courage to continue doing
it you know there's so much cynicism and
hopelessness we were talking last night
about
how cynical people are and i think you
just have to keep going i i really do
because
you get caught in a trap of being
defensive like responding to their bias
and whining about them
and what i found is if you just keep
reporting they keep attacking me i just
keep reporting and
i think the audience that you're serving
right here this stream right now and the
audience i serve
these are new audiences these are people
who don't necessarily watch cnn
or maybe even watch fox news they're
just people that are being enlightened
little by little
and the truth is tim i think we're
winning i mean i think
i've got more sources coming to me than
ever before people people the sources
tell me i've got no place else to go
they say i can't go with the new york
times i mean i can't go to usa today
those i don't even know what usa today
is
exceptional pieces about us so let's do
this we i think i'm going to really
enjoy ragging on the media but
we should give it we should get that we
should talk about it so let me do this
you've you've exposed this
you you had another video of uh a
director at google talking about
censorship that that woman
i forgot what her position was what was
the name of the woman at google
uh the irish woman you've had a couple
so jen's and i the big the big one was
genji and i
saying we need to have algorithmic
fairness yeah because
god forbid you google search something
and you get reality or facts
what if the facts are unfair so we have
to do is censor the reality such that it
makes the world more fair who defines
fair we don't know
and then genji says we've got to prevent
the next
trump situation this is what jinai says
who's a senior
individual google head of innovation
google's innovation department so when
she said we have to prevent the next
trump situation
uh was it was it a smoking gun not quite
because what did she mean by that now
she'll say on the medium she wrote an
article no no i meant stop russian
interference in the election oh yeah so
they'll say whatever they need to say
to to explain away their comments on the
tape
have you seen the social dilemma just a
few minutes of downstairs yeah we were
we were playing just a bit of it
downstairs and what's really interesting
is
is they they basically confirm
everything
you've got on camera you've got former
tech executives they don't they don't go
as deep as to say
yeah when we were there we were like
we're gonna we're gonna make sure the
democrats win
but they were straight up saying we
manipulate people into doing what we
want them to do
we figure out how to persuade them into
doing what we want them to do
and then i see stories like that like
you know so in
uh in the documentary they have this
mock version
of political extremism called the
extreme center and don't vote like these
two groups that are fighting each other
but it's very clear that they're
straight up saying social media
companies are
encouraging you know are favoring
political factions or institutions
and considering we're seeing something
like this it reminds me of what we heard
from the ceo of reddit
i don't know if you're familiar with
this but he actually said i'm confident
reddit could swing
could sway an election we wouldn't do it
then what do they do now they're
actively censoring you know
conservatives trump supporters
so we're seeing this kind of thing just
basically across the board
i guess i'll just uh ask you we have the
story all right so
you know i don't know what else uh to
say about it to say about well this one
individual
so i'm gonna ask you yeah to with with
all of the
exposes you've done on google so far
give us the big picture of what's
happening with google with facebook with
twitter
from this story to the other stories
you've done right well you know and and
i think video
has said this many times video
transfixes in a way that words don't so
kind of hearing
these people talk about what how they do
this and what they do
with the uh first with the google clip
we were talking about a moment ago women
say we got
prevent the next trump situation uh this
guy
saying it seems they favor democrats
with their algorithms
um uh there's a there's a it's it's
becoming more
obvious it's becoming more clear that
there is no
shame on these platforms and i think the
recent
new york post story was a good example
of that where it's just it's just
it's no longer you need a hidden camera
they're just doing it out in the open
and and and i still believe that if the
content
the story is good enough it can
circumvent the powers that be because
people are hungry for real raw
enlightened information so that that's
my premise if that premise is off or if
that's wrong then
maybe this escalates into the next
defcon stage which
is civil unrest in this country but i i
still believe
fundamentally that people are
intelligent enough to
be receptive to real and raw information
like you're seeing with project veritas
and what's more tim is and i can't
emphasize this enough for your show
veritas's vision is insiders and
whistleblowers coming public brave
people that's why our motto is be brave
do something so when i do something like
this what happens is
six google insiders will contact me and
say hey bro
i've seen this i don't want to lose my
job but here's a you know yeah
encrypted and then it's like this army
of people because they can stop one man
but they can't stop a thousand people
you know i mean that's like this idea of
an army a thousand insiders sending
information at the same time well
this guy ritesh i feel bad for him i
mean
he's gonna get a lot of unwanted
attention he's being honest yeah you
know he says in this clip
if the what does he say if trump wins
they'll be riots if the left wins
they'll be ecstatic
yes i mean he's being he's being honest
about what's happening in this country
he tells you
you know candidly what's happening i
feel bad because
you know i don't want i don't want this
guy to go through any hardship or
anything because of this
the problem is what happens when no one
is willing to step forward and tell you
what's actually happening and they're
actively participating in it you know
the ethics of
i had this conversation with a guy named
eric weinstein on his podcast for like
two hours about this ethics of blurring
faith very fascinating very very
you know intellectual conversation but i
was telling my staff that
you know ernest hemingway once said what
is moral is what you feel good after and
what is immoral is what you feel bad
after
morally defensible journalism is rarely
what you feel good about afterwards is
only that which makes you feel better
than you would otherwise
so it's like eating coal in the forest
to help your stomach
it never feels good but you feel better
after you do it undercover work is
is is is tough people don't like it it's
like you're filming someone without them
knowing sometimes they're good people
sometimes they're bad people
in this case this guy is probably some
combination of somewhere in between
right but the public's right to know is
paramount
and we're better off for knowing this
information do i do
i don't like harming people that's not
the intent of this we're not trying to
shame people
we're trying to it the public what's
more important
than a monopoly on a search engine
telling you we're trying to elect this
guy
nothing's more important than that so
and it's a public place or in a
restaurant so
it's a very interesting ethical
conversation i suppose but i think we
need more of this sort of thing not less
of it
i agree though yeah yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you